foreign
countries like my home country of Kenya
mental health problems prevent young
people from living independent and
successful lives
I was born and raised in small sugarcane
farm some of my early memories that also
my younger brother and I walking around
and pretending that we earned the
sugarcane
but most of these memories were actually
from school
my parents and especially my mother made
sure that I knew how much it sacrificed
for me to have the education and the
path to success that they did not
they were very clear that his checks
were too high there was no room for
disappointment there was no room for
failure
when I was 12 I moved to the budding
section of a local Primary School
here we will wake up at 4am to a site of
math problems so we got resolved before
breakfast
we'd only go to bed sometimes after 11
if we solved that ninth science problems
in high school the pressure was even
higher the early morning to late night
routines were Now supplemented by
Saturday and Sunday classes
it was here in high school where I began
to notice the personal emotional and
behavioral child that is pressure cooker
system had exerted it myself and those
around me
I noticed it for example when tired of
cramming the production of sulfuric acid
I stopped taking notes or engaging with
chemistry in 10th Grade
I noticed it when my friend on songo
tired that his life had been reduced to
a letter great had enough and quit
school
I noticed it when a school meant whom I
will call her piano
took his own life
but all this time
all this time what came to mind was that
this was life
life was trouble sleeping or sleeping
too much
life was little interest or pleasure in
doing the things that gave you Joy
life was constantly feeling down
crashing under the weight and or the
feelings of hopelessness
that was life
it was only recently some five years
after high school that I began to
realize that what we thought was life
could have in fact been mental health
problems
was it possible that we were struggling
with depression and anxiety and just
didn't know about it
that in fact was the kiss
studies now showed that almost 50
percent of Kenyans or dollar signs
struggle with mental health problems
and in such a youthful country where
half the population is 19 years or
younger youth mental health has now
become an agent Public Health priority
over the past few years I've been
working to turn this public health
problem into an opportunity for young
people to remind and to Define what
mental health care could look like
we are doing this by tackling the three
big issues that prevent young people
from getting help
one the lack of mental health experts
two the stigma around mental health and
three the sad reality that most mental
health treatments will not build and
designed for young people who look like
me and have my background
because we have only two clinicians for
every one million Kenyans and two yes
only two child that adolescent
psychiatrists in the whole country we
are expanding Mental Health Care access
by training 18 to 22 young Kenyans and
slave providers
these young Kenyans are delivering
evidence-based care to the peers through
a structured and tiered model that
ensures that all young people who want
can get help
because of a stigma of mental health
that still exists from Kenya's Colonial
past we are delivering interventions
without a formal diagnosis of mental
health and our interventions focus on
building character strengths on
strengthening individual autonomy around
improving overall human functioning and
well-being
because our lay providers work within
the communities where they come from in
the school systems that they themselves
went to and deliver what is truly a full
Youth and by youth Mental Health Care
treatment we are fixing the Divide
between mental health treatments in the
social and cultural needs of the
communities that they serve
since 2018 we have used this used based
model to bring a mental health care
across Kenya and what we have found is
that this model work
young people are reporting reductions in
depression anxiety symptoms
the reporting improvements in the social
relationships and in the views about the
abilities to change their world
and in what will make my mom happy they
are also reporting improvements in the
academic grades
mental health is not a Kenyan problem
it is not an African problem
this is a global problem we need big
ideas to tackle this problem
in our case for optimism is that our
youth oriented Community focused model
can be a template for the rest of the
world
one other early memory from childhood is
a story that my grandmother United told
me
long time ago before the sugarcane Farms
before the grass touched hearts and the
round compounds the animals lived
happily because there was plenty in the
line in the future to look forward to
famine threatened the land and the
future was all of a sudden bleak
and so the lion roared
but there was no water
and the Elephant granted
but there was no water
and the cheetah yelped
but there was no water
but when the young Antelope asked them
to come together and build a well
there was water
there was a future
there was hope
this is our young Antelope moment
let us come together and let us build a
world where all young people all over
the world can flourish and Thrive thank
you
[Applause]